ouais
[Musique]
à
ce jeune agriculteur n'est pas en train
de jouer sur son smartphone l'ong il
peaufine ses réglages pour la livraison
du déjeuner de son cheptel
une petite révolution dans le sud de la
tour est
ici faut savoir qu'on mise absolument
sur l'autonomie au niveau de
l'alimentation
donc là dans la cuisine on peut
retrouver de la luzerne de la paille ici
c'est de l'ensilage de maïs de
l'ensilage d'herbe sous le bâtiment le
robot c'est l'emplacement des différents
stades des animaux et donc si c'est une
vache laitière il va donner la ration
spécifique à l
et si c'est une génisse silva a donné
une génération différente
24 heures sur 24 365 jours par an ce
robot est au service d'une centaine de
prim'holstein jersiaise et normandes ici
les vaches donc elles sont totalement
libres elle mange quand elles veulent et
puis voilà quand elles ont envie d'aller
se faire traire elles vont au robot
automatique ensuite
c'est pareil elles ont des logettes pour
se coucher quand elles veulent donc à
peu près 13 heures par jour et
ça
ça permet d'être au top au niveau bien
être des animaux
dans la famille maurice c'est antoine
qui a la responsabilité de la production
laitière après un bac scientifique il ne
serait jamais revenu à la ferme aider sa
mère viviane si la robotisation n'avait
pas été mise en place
ne voyait pas à 50 ans comme mes parents
et des anglais tente ne plus avoir des
pôles que la traite c'est trop dur etc
la qualité de vie aujourd'hui c'est
aussi primordial dans les futurs
connecté au collier des vaches ce robot
de traite est capable de détecter les
pies grâce à des capteurs de mesure et
le lait récoltés et de connaître les
têtes santé instantanément de la vache
cet android développé par les hollandais
a coûté 100 mille euros le prix pour
apprécier le quotidien
la pénibilité
les bras qui commence vraiment à
fatiguer une corde qui fatigue et puis
le temps que l'on y passe là on passe
autant de temps mais avec une certaine
liberté tout de même
quand on a goûté à ça nous le matin si
enfin le dimanche matin surtout un vais
pas appeler la fête le samedi
vous il est à 8h10 n'est à cette heure
gilles à 9 heures les robots ont fait
leur boulot hein vous êtes là pour
fignoler mais non royanno mon nom
[Musique]
la robotisation mois pour moi oui c'est
l'avenir ce qu'ils en ont peur c'est
peut-être ce qui appréhende de s'en
servir pas de la voir mais de s'en
servir fini donc la traite deux fois par
jour antoine sixième générations
d'éleveurs chez les morris a désormais
du temps précieux pour s'occuper et
choyer ses bêtes
[Musique]
l'innovation technologique l'innovation
digitale au service de la filière
agricole en centre val de loire les
idées ne manquent pas
au nord de chartres dans son tracteur
luc laurin est a priori un agriculteur
comme les autres s'il exerce bien son
métier d'exploitant céréaliers sur 320
hectares avec son frère ce n'est pas là
l'essentiel de son activité
mathématicien météorologues et
agriculteurs
il est un peu les trois à la fois ce géo
trouvetou a recueilli en trente ans un
nombre incalculable de métadonnées dans
le monde entier pour mieux anticiper
c'est la passion de mon métier la
passion des mathématiques la passion
d'agronomie la physiologie toute plante
je suis né avec une paire de bottes un
ordinateur alors déjà donné ses dates
données de data de météo tu as donné de
relever ce stade dans tous les pays du
monde de rendement
de certains pays de certaines régions et
tout ça j'ai tout doux tout agrémenté
pour planifier pour chacun des pays et
l'objectif pour moi c'est de
de prévoir parfois incompris en france
considéré comme un original par les
coopératives la filière luc laurent a
développé essentiellement son idée
ailleurs en proposant des outils d aide
à la décision en europe de l'est sarah
par exemple en france j'ai pas pu ça
fait 20 ans que le faire j'ai pas pu le
faire les en trois ans aux mamies qui
s'était clos au gore ça fait deux ans
j'ai connu c'est une start up qui
récupère des images un dvi et des images
satellites et à partir de ces images
satellites l'idée c'est de déterminer de
mettre en place différents os à des
prévisions de rendement risque maladie
etc à partir de kim à chaque été données
météo pour apporter des outils d'aidé à
la décision pour les agriculteurs donc
en roumanie on s'occupe de 2,7 lui ferme
qui ont entre 2 et 15 ville état
[Musique]
certains ne sont pas allés à l'autre
bout du monde proposer leurs produits
mais au bout du champ
salut florian
te ramène la caméra
xavier chabane agriculteurs lui aussi
avait identifié un besoin spécifique
alors il a élaboré une caméra connecter
pour la surveillance du système
d'arrosage
plus besoin de se déplacer pour vérifier
si tout va bien c'est un outil qui est
très autonome mais qu'il manque beaucoup
de surveillance jour et nuit savoir ça
fonctionne on voit ça m'évite les
allers-retours j'ai deux sites je
m'occupe beaucoup de l'autre site avec
les enrouleurs donc là ça permet d'être
autonome
donc pas les relie donc là c'est bon
voilà donc là tu peux vérifier
à pékin 2 essaye de la bougie des
économies de carburant de la fatigue en
moins plus de temps en famille exerçait
son métier d'exploitant agricole semble
a priori plus facile
disons que les outils technologiques
amène de la facilité par contre
aujourd'hui un agriculteur et gère une
plus grande surface avec beaucoup plus
de contraintes et donc est ce que c'est
plus facile je suis pas certain mais le
volume horaire et la charge de travail
n'est pas la même tout le monde n'est
pas au top de la technologie sur les
exploitations malgré tout le gps le
guidage par gps il ya dix ans il n'avait
presque pas aujourd'hui on est plus de
50 % des exploitations qui en ont donc
les marches évolué ça va très très vite
et si c'est pas par la technique c'est
par la technologie
son idée de caméras connectées c'est ici
que xavier chabane l'a mûri et
développer
bonjour je dis ça travaillez vous
bah c'est pas facile mais bon la moisson
n'est pas simple des start up et du
monde
et
un des lieux référence de l'innovation
agricole en france l'incubateur de start
up les champs du possible à châteaudun
au coeur de la beauce comme d'autres
xavier ne pouvait rester seul dans son
coin il est donc venu dans ce campus un
écosystème dynamique combinant
partenaires privés et publics qui
propose aide et soutien pour élaborer
son business
on en a beaucoup qui dans les startups
heures qui sont aussi agriculteur dont
qui ont vraiment cette connaissance
terrain mais effectivement après il faut
la valider plus largement il faut la
valider commercialement il faut valider
la faisabilité technique la faisabilité
juridique économique extra trouver le
bon business model et nous c'est
vraiment notre rôle ici de les
accompagner vraiment sur ces sujets là
aujourd'hui 15 start up françaises sont
hébergés ici avec un objectif d'inventer
l'agriculture du futur maintenant
c'est pour toi je tends contre
j'ai tant concombres en quatre cinq
bloqués jusqu'à août
oui jusqu'à fin août
alban et arthur deux cousins se sont
lancés dans l'aventuré il ya seulement
quelques mois avec une idée simple une
place de marché numérique 100% bio 100%
équitable vous avez vraiment l'ensemble
de chacun des produits disponibles chez
le producteur est en fait l'idée c'est
d'avoir directement en fait en temps
réel toutes les informations concernant
ce produit le stock disponible chez les
producteurs en temps réel avec bien sûr
le coup en départ parce que nous
travaillons sur un prix départ puce
transport pour apporter plus de
transparence sur le véritable coût du
produit et combien ça nous coûte de
l'acheminer directement le lendemain
chez nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous retrouvons luc notre data culteurs
passé lui aussi par le campus de
start-up agricole ce jeudi il a rejoint
un de ces rares clients français
comporte son argent on te croit
on voit bien les dégâts de celle du mois
d'avril
[Musique]
grâce aux outils d aide à la décision et
à l'analyse précise réalisée par luc
laurin christophe barret a vendu avant
la moisson l'essentiel de sa future
production d'orge
concrètement j'ai vendu 100 % de mon
ange voilà un outil vise grâce à l'outil
parce que en ayant une estimation de
rendement mon acheteur a bien voulu
acheter une surface avec un rendement
dont on n'a pas la certitude du tonnage
pour l'instant mais on a quand même un
élément concret qui est l'estimation
donc ça c'est assez nouveau jusque là on
ne vend que des tonnages et moi
aujourd'hui j'ai vendu des ha c'est très
simple d'utilisation parce que on reçoit
quatre pages alors après le service il
peut être plus ou moins complet c'est à
la carte mais moi je reçois quatre pages
tous les quinze jours et et ça me dit
tout pour pour toutes les cultures quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le grand saut se projeter dans
l'innovation numérique alban et arthur
l'ont fait il ya quelques mois avec leur
marketplace digital 100% bio 100%
circuits courts
celles là sont supers on voit bien les
fleurs et tout et puis là elles ont pris
de pucerons en travaillant sur leur
concept et sur les opportunités de
marché ses fils d'agriculteurs ont même
soumis l'idée au père d'alban de se
lancer en val de loire dans la
production de pastèques moi j'arrive en
fin de carrière je m'aime je devrais
presque est arrêté mais ça me plaît
d'innover et puis je vois qu'il y avait
plein de choses à faire et puis ce qu'il
faut c'est produire mais vendent si vous
produisez vous n'êtes pas capable de le
vendre c'est pas la peine le numérique
une arme absolue mais rien ne pourra
donc se faire sans un produit de qualité
le but c'est que le monde puisse vivre
de son métier un agriculteur ça avant
tout un artisan nous aujourd'hui on
essaye justement via le digital
d'apporter d'autres solutions d'autres
manières de travailler et le vue
touristique tourne depuis ses envies
bien évidemment on sait d'où on vient a
barh garder en des temps ben voilà
deschamps et c'est vrai que c'est ce
qu'on nous a appris le travail au
quotidien et ce qu'on essaie de faire
pour valoriser cette belle production
française
[Musique]
simplification des process gain de temps
de rentabilité la grille tech est en
plein boom reste à savoir si son
objectif de faciliter le travail des
agriculteurs et de mieux les rémunérer
sera respectée
[Musique]